I need like a little mirror
are you sure my hair looks fine yeah I
love your hair your hair is the best
part I try to present like you know in
Palace is not homeless you know because
being homeless you treated a lot
differently you know
I guess it's easier when you look like
you're yeah like I'm having a good day
today because I had it come up you know
I had somebody
a sugar daddy basically give me 40 bucks
so I was able to get like everything I
needed I got my MacArthur Park down on
Alvarado I got my three dollar pack of
cigarettes uh views Xanax bars
um half a gramafetti
um and the guy who gave me the money
also gave me crystal it's about a pipe
so I'm saying good right now but you
know talk to me again in like eight
hours and I'll be you know different
story I'll look like a different person
you know unless I leave right now in
Hustle the fact that I'm getting 100
from this
I'm gonna have a good next three days
where are you from Kenneth I'm from
Elkhart Indiana yeah yeah Northern
Indiana Yeah by South Bend yeah tell me
about your family growing up
um honestly this would have been really
nothing interesting about that or any of
them
um I lived in a trailer park until we
moved to like this tiny little house in
Elkhart
um when I was in the third grade my
parents separated it uh when I was like
20. uh it was good what was your
childhood like how would you describe it
um
I was a sad kid I
I felt you know different I knew I was
different I knew I was gay
you know and I was confused when people
how people would respond to me when I
was just being myself
so I had to like learn to you know
pretty much create another personality
and persona
to to present like you were straight
yeah and I have to and I you know in
certain areas I have to do that here
like that's the way I brought like the
Lakers so I can think I'll put my hair
away I'll wear like a normal pair of
sunglasses not something like this like
Fuji
um I won't be showing like the gold
chain in the you know that's why you get
roughed up a little bit I've been I've
been Robin and assaulted so many times
that
yeah I try I try I try to blend in but
unfortunately especially when I was in
the Indiana I stand out
and out it's a little bit and I'm a
Target and I put myself in these
situations and places to be at Target
yeah
drugs became a part of your life when
it's funny I never even drank alcohol
until I graduated high school
when I was 17 I started with pot
um and once I smoked
I couldn't stop it became like there's
like a physical allergy you know where I
I literally just like and I didn't think
anything was off about it I thought
that's how everybody was you know when
she's once you started you just continue
to do it all day you know and then your
life revolves around it
um and my parents tried to get through
my head like everyone's not an addict
and you're gonna start hanging out with
normal people
but like what's normal
why do you think there's something
different like I've done the AAA 12
steps I've relapsed several times
but the addiction
is so misunderstood by our society
um they don't get the concept of the
physical allergy and the mental
objection
um
if I had a choice
I would I wouldn't do the things that I
do to have
to get drugs I don't want to go do fat
at all
but I have to or or I'll be sick you
know how do you first get fentanyl in
your system
um you were doing something else after I
left Las Vegas uh when I was 20 I only
lived there for like three months and
then this uh these clients that I had a
couple from New York wanted me to move
in with them and I said no but can you
fly me home so they they flew me back to
Indiana
um and probably saved my life but then I
started using them it was a geographic I
started using heroin I was like okay
this method is not working anymore so
I'll try heroin and then
when I was out here in California about
when I was 23 probably like three years
ago fentanyl was really starting to come
up
um I had a friend tell me that you can
get it on Craigslist all you have to do
is type in white champagne
he's having white chatting plates and if
you find people who will deliver it to
you I've had fentanyl delivered to
rehabs for me type in what white China
plates there's words in this like code
words
for the drugs but this was years ago I'm
pretty sure like it's shut down now like
you know it's changed or whatever yeah I
don't think I'm pretty sure
uh I'm 27 27. yeah 1996. you've been in
La for how long
um kind of on two years
you've been homeless the whole time no
uh basically since I moved to California
October 12 2018 I've been living in
rehab facilities
in our rehabs was there a time when you
were doing well you had money and oh
yeah just recently I was a house manager
for a rehab
before the drugs kind of took hold
I was a great student
I had full ride scholarship to IUPUI in
Indianapolis I was supposed to
be in the field of working with people's
best special needs like cognitive on the
developmental disabilities
but I
I lost everything when because of the
drugs you know the drugs got you into
frustration or the prostitution got you
into drugs
so I wasn't doing hard drugs before I
became a prostitute like I couldn't
control the Adderall and alcohol in
college
I had like a manic episode and I'm not
diagnosed with anything so I'm not gonna
self-diagnose but it was like a bipolar
make episode where I randomly left and I
was like I'm going to the West Coast
[__] this life I was stressed out as you
know couldn't show up to [__] class
uh I couldn't I just owed people money I
was like overwhelmed mental breakdown
my car breaks down in North Las Vegas
what do I do
I have like
eight hundred dollars you know
that I'd stolen from my roommates that
I've yet to pay back
I've been in contact I worked this steps
and I made amends
but
like when I was just recently doing the
steps
um when I was a medical detox and Rehab
just earlier this year I was impatient
for 124 days
um I got through all the steps but I
didn't do step 12 and sponsor anybody
I showed up to a conference for the
Fellowship of the spirit like me
high on DMZ
I I relapsed some [__]
uh shrooms and DMG and then I decided
I'll go do crack
I got drunk before so I don't even
remember how it felt
I've done crack like three times since
then but it's not for me I'm I'm a
trigger and a junkie unfortunately
a smoker I think you're meaning crystal
meth and junkie meaning heroin
professional Fentanyl
for me
with my tolerance
I needed at least to not be sick and
just feel I could feel I could get by
with a dub so twenty dollars
but like I just about half for 30 years
so I'm very I'm gonna be hot you know
and then I've been doing it and on the
street since September every day I've
had two other doses that happened in
September but I have not overdose since
I heard you run into Rebecca sometimes
in West Hollywood yeah I know Rebecca
[__] she's crazy who's not doing well
lately
yeah she she was interesting I was like
I know you I've seen you I'm like right
super talented and bright
but super self-destructive at the same
time oh yeah I really yeah you know
that's what I've always been told like
can why are you doing this you have so
much potential you know yeah but there's
like the self-destructive people well
people don't understand addiction they
think that I'm choosing
to have this lifestyle but like I
literally
unless something happens and it has to
be like
a God moment where like
some opportunity like something like I'm
gonna end up in jail which if I did I
ended up in Los Angeles County Jail I
would I'll be I'll get raped I'll be
beaten you know
I've been caught like like to get by a
boost I like go to stores they steal
[__] and they sell it over on Alvarado
I'm not proud of that you know
I go to big corporations like I'm not
gonna name them obviously but
I feel like I have no other choice
you know I want to get a normal job but
I can't function like it took me a week
and a half to even get here you know I
tried I've been trying to get here but
like you know I'm I'm so caught up in my
addiction where do you sleep at night or
do you sleep well just recently I got
lucky I got a knee infection
um so I went to see her Cyanide and the
social worker
um put me into
um I'm not gonna say the name of the
facility but it's a short-term stay so I
have indoor living right now and I'm
trying I'm trying to get into the tiny
homes with hope of the valley
um see the action center I've done their
intake I was on the waiting list and
then I had my phone still in no but
you're intelligent you're college
educated you would think you could
get a job yeah
I just recently worked like I haven't
worked now since
it's been a year now because we're in
February like like February 1st was when
I was kicked out of being a house
manager
um and a server for Saint Felix and host
and then I was on the street and then I
you know I was right off and I was using
and then I went to you know did the 124
day stay
um I did a private insurance
um detox for three weeks and then I did
a 90 day with medical so my parents
didn't have to pay the 700 for Cobra
Insurance because once you turn 25 you
don't get that BPO
unless you get your own job and pay for
insurance I no longer on my Jasmine
shirts so I can't just in a moment at a
moments notice call and have
then uh send me an Uber you know to go
that's not how medical works the private
insurance industry uh for rehabs is is
different people on the spot send you an
Uber and you could go right now
with Medi-Cal you have to wait you have
to call every day
you get on waitlist it's like but like
I could die at any moment you know
and I I'm like I've always thought I
would not make it to 30. if you OD'd I
have ID twice I've ided upstairs
um at MacArthur Park in the uh train
station upstairs
the cops and no one knows it's got
Narcan and then you know because there's
other people sitting and smoking I got
up
social Crystal
I had a big headache
and then an hour went by and I was using
that all again this is your lowest point
right now your life
no because I'm not I'm not on the street
you're on the streets right I'm off the
streets yeah
yeah if you can blurt this part out I'm
I'm at the National Health Foundation
yeah I see it one of their facilities
and I have a caseworker who's trying
trying to get me in but I have a bed to
go to no but but if it weren't for the
drugs you could get your life together
oh my God yeah I would have a master's
degree I'd be a teacher a special
education teacher
and I know that
yeah drugs have unraveled and everything
yeah like I know I know my I know my
purpose but because
of addiction
I I can't fulfill it because
it's hard to explain like unless you
there's like a lyric of this song
mentally she's regulation unless you
never lived through it don't [__]
talk about it
sorry
it's so misunderstood
when I'm like I walked out of [__]
Pavilions and [__]
uh
like 12 day 12 you know Tupac you should
get five dollars and I'm like crying
because so
how I want to live
but I'm gonna be sick you know
are there other addicts in your family
yeah I found out that my dad did uh when
I was like two years old there was a
year where my dad was using crack
um he quit and he didn't tell me that
until I was like 22. he didn't open up
and see me and then when he told me I
was like why did you ever tell me this
you've seen me like struggling now for
like you know years like
it could have helped
you know but he's changed so much and I
love my family so much but
There's Hope for you
that knows not correct though fentanyl's
tough
yeah
I'm not anymore I you know I have to be
out of bed though
unfortunately
like that's the progression
so that's why I use crystal
and it's it's [__] it's such a chore
you know trying to keep up with it
it's a waste of time I feel like I'm a
waste
of a vessel you know
I could be doing so much more but I
don't I don't know why like emotionally
what do you go through
this so I really I really need this
right now because I haven't I haven't
cried in a long time and this energy a
good story
and you know and then it needs to be
released
I give you so much shame and go
the things I've done to people
the selfishness the self-centeredness of
the the disease and it is a disease
and then you'd end up doing things that
cause a lot of Shame and then the shame
makes you depressed and
makes you want to use myself
sorry I'm almost to the point where I
want to kill myself
like I want to die but I'm not gonna I'm
not I can't I can't overdose like I
haven't overdosed since September you
know you shouldn't do that I mean there
are people who have gotten clean from
fentanyl
I know I can clean from all these drugs
uh my my old sponsor he never he was
meth in heroin because you guys ever
before fentanyl she's been sober now for
six seven years
he's an amazing person but I am two
hundred dollars
you know
I'm a piece of [__] I didn't pay him
back I think fentanyl's like a whole new
game for everybody
it's tough
I appreciated it it's the devil
I can't even explain like the pain of
coming down from Fentanyl and benzos and
like even if you don't buy Xanax some
some of the people who are making it are
putting it in there you know it's pretty
much I've gone to detoxes and I pop for
[__] benzos but I I did Fat no
it was nice with benzo well you were
probably never intending on being an
opiate addict right no you just want to
use crystal meth but you probably got
something yeah I remember those ads
they're on TV like the Faces of Meth uh
campaign
this isn't that you know that's not true
you never know give it time though give
it time yeah oh yeah give me 20 years
and I might be busted yeah beautiful
teeth right now but right now but I just
saw a dentist uh three days ago last
week and I had a second
on Thursday and I didn't make it
and I just traded my vape for a [__]
phone
um
down in uh the train station at
MacArthur Park and
um he got my ass because it's in Spanish
and I don't know how to Res like factory
reset I don't know how to speak Spanish
like I don't know how to change it to
English like
maybe I'll just go to the one of the
tents and ask if they can figure it out
or like one of the people that I trust
down there but I [__] hate going to
MacArthur Park I get my [__] and I go
and if I don't if it's midnight and the
Train shut down
and I stay there bad things happen you
know
if like in February there were nine
bodies and the pond just in that one
month is that right
yeah because I don't really want to talk
about like the gang related stuff I'm
not in a game I'm not affiliated I just
I didn't know anything about about it
you know I didn't know that like if I
went to this person to buy fight at all
that you know the other person
finds out that I'm not buying from him
and no longer buying from him and buying
from somebody who is a part of another
gang so they start selling me fake [__]
you know
I've been robbed because I was trying
you know I got I thought I got
permission from like an old timer
in a um
I don't know if you've ever heard of the
gang um
it's the gay boy gangsters
[Music]
um you've heard about it yeah but I read
somebody who's a part of the West the
they're speaking Spanish and I knew that
he was about to rob me so I rode my bike
down the street and somehow he ends up
on an electric scooter
and catches up to me on the corner of
Alvarado in six and he's mad and he
threatens to stab me and I just gave him
everything except for he didn't want the
bike
psychosis where like I
you know I just walked for hours like I
just picked up a dub from this old-timer
game boy gangster
um I don't do a lot of Crystal super
sensitive to it like you know
I do it to get up and get going
and figure out how I'm gonna get more
fat and all you know
I guess so I could get out of bed
um so I wanted to sell it so if you
could live your life over again what
would you have done differently
over again what would I have done
differently
I would have never
drink alcohol
I just I can't take the first one you
know
I've just never done a drag
because if I didn't overall I would just
be an alcoholic you know
I would have never
you know I didn't choose to have that
manic episode where I moved to Las Vegas
that was random and weird you know my
car broke down
and I ran out of money so to survive but
like I did what I had to do and I sold
my body I escorted on the Strip that was
where it started that's really excited
it was hard living there because
everybody's a Taurus and travels and the
locals are nasty people
I never went to the underground tunnels
but I've heard about them
um the locals I knew and that were doing
what I was doing
introducing me to math and they look
they look like me they didn't look like
the faces of mess campaign
you know
yeah
they made it look glamorous
and it has such a stigma you know but
meth is nasty but like cocaine
you know people are like bumping in the
club and like
and they're like you know Versace shoes
red bottoms or whatever and it's cool
but like
addiction's so misunderstood you know
what do you think the biggest
misunderstanding is
that's a choice
that we're choosing
just like being gay I'd choose to be gay
it's kind of I wish I would like I'm
actually it's like that I love being gay
you know I love going to we are hot I'm
proud to be gay
I'm proud that I got I I've been able to
live a life where I've gotten of Indiana
because my sisters like they they've
never even been to a state boarding like
they've only been to the bordering
states of Indiana
you know I've got to you know do some
cool [__]
um in vehicle park community that is
happy and fun but
some people you know still don't like it
like literally yesterday I was staying
at a park bench and the guy told me to
stop talking uh like he started to mimic
how I speak
and he's like can you stop doing that
and then my friend was like yo that's
just kind of that's like and I was like
I I can't change my accent you know to
have to like think about how you're
talking and how your mannerism and how
you move that takes a lot of energy you
know
but like people be hating on me because
like I could unpack like I pass is not
homeless and like I have you know nice
things sometimes
um
but I gotta be careful you know
because people have come up to me in the
subway stations on Hollywood and Western
and he was like this random guy no idea
who he is he goes are you kidding I
should have said [__] no but I didn't
do anything so I said yeah he punches me
in the face and he grabs my backpack and
he runs and he goes and he grabs the I
just got in a sleeping bag I was on the
street
they're handing them out for Christmas
at MacArthur Park
he takes it and he starts out onto the
rail but then he takes my backpack walks
upstairs and leaves
what did I do
you know it was targeted
I was talking about why
you know I try to have morals you know
I don't want to steal from people
I'm to the point where I can't even
steal from like corporations
I'm probably gonna just go back into sex
work
how long do you do that
I did it for like a year
and when I stopped I couldn't have
normal sex for like a year it [__] me
up
because like you're being like bought as
an item you know and I'm not I'm a
person
um
it's so it's so demeaning you know I'm
spiritual like this is my temple
and I tell other people know that I've
been raped
mostly you know
I get geed out
on jhb
just last night I was falling asleep in
the guy's apartment and I wanted to go
to sleep and he
he was he he just I don't actually want
to talk about him in this interview
because I love him
um but it was it was
you know people do think and I'm not mad
at him because he was under substance
his his behaviors
were a result of the control that the
substance has on him the grip of the
substance
you know
and then he wakes up and he doesn't
remember any of it of course and I knew
he wouldn't
I was like yeah I put your [__] in the
laundry because you shot on the pizza
you know the cops were coming because he
wouldn't stop stomping so I hit all you
know the illegal [__] I said I put it I
put it in your top drawer and he wakes
up and he can't find anything and he
like you know we do things
um
especially with downers like yo and if
you aren't staying hydrated and eating
you'll black out and like literally do
things so like I don't know maybe I was
targeted that day because I did
something in a Blackout
um there's been two times in the two or
three times where I woke up in Santa
Monica
and I didn't have pants on
and I couldn't remember anything
in that last time
uh it was so bad that it made me leave
and no longer wanted me almost there
um because my genitals hurt I woke up
and everything is still in I had no
pants on
in my channels for her not like her so I
don't know what happened but
you could you know put the pieces
together
what's your biggest fear
I'm scared of everything that's the hard
question because I'm scared
getting murdered
because I'm not gonna die people I I
unfortunately like I've met I've been
involved with nasty people
but I'd be fighting on Xanax and I have
a tolerance so you can't kill me
unfortunately with that at all so like
when somebody wants to to kill me it's
gonna have to be violent and we have to
get shot
or drown you know
because drugs are gonna do it
but I think I think there's hope I think
God does have a plan for me
I think there's a reason why I'm not
dead yet
last like in a year like nine months
three like my friends like two original
I live with died
to die
because
so valuable
you know
like you're getting tribute so much
I was recently sober living in Pasadena
in the summer
and right before I realized I had two
interviews set up to uh be a teacher's
aide for special needs kids you know
why would you relapse when you're
finally getting your your life together
um
I don't know my roommate a bunch of
people in the house had relapsed and
left and I was alone in my room
I got obsessed with like
at least hallucinogenics and the fact
that I've never tried them I thought
that maybe if I went out and did you
know GMT
that it could be an alternative
um what what do they call it like with
marijuana harm reduction
um but that's just so expensive and the
government puts such like the laws like
like you know it's just like it's so
hard to get it it looks like 150 is a
[__] gram you know if I could walk
and get [__] ready for five bucks
this was my broke [__] ass gonna do you
know I'm not gonna do the spiritual drag
I'm not gonna go meet God
you know
there's another lyric in that song for
the meth pipe it's glass rose the devil
has me in his last last lasso into the
Gates of Hell something something but
like
I don't believe in the devil but I do
believe in energies and
Karma
generational Karma you know
I think we live multiple lives
I think I'm supposed to fulfill my
purpose and then
if I don't if I die because of this
lifestyle
I think our spirit gets another chance
but we get to move up or ascend
until we fulfill that purpose you know
that's what I believe
I know exactly what I need to do you
know
I need to go to rehab I need to accept
and I need to sponsor people I need to
you know
but I need to get [__] sober
it's not that easy as you think you know
okay you can't just be like okay I'll go
no God's Gonna choose when it's time for
me to go
my experiences
are happening so that I can share them
with people in the future
um they say that connection is the
opposite of addiction there's a reason
why you know all these things has
happened to me because there's another
little gay boy out there
that hopefully one day I'll be able to
sponsor
and you know he'll be able to open up
and relate
to me
it made me meet God you know
but it's a lot of work
this the when I did the it's up making
making the list
um I did not index cards and I had like
140 of them
I did 40 or 50.
but it wasn't enough to have the psychic
change you know
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in all this
the most important thing that I've
learned
but the father's first
don't be a selfish
self-centeredness
so like they say it's a revoluable
and with drugs that becomes so
self-consumed
I think I'm a [__] model you know
like someone I'm walking down Sunset
Boulevard and some random guy uh
hands me his card and asked asked me to
come in for or to call him after the
weekend on Monday
um I was in the industry
um
and I couldn't even do that I didn't
have a phone I can make money modeling
you know
but I'm starting to fall apart
not going to be pretty forever
you know
all right Kenneth thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you for having me I hope you I
hope you find it
a rehab or a program that can help you
stay on track
me too
yeah you're young you can do it yeah I
just hope What receives this because I
believe in the power prayer
praise for me
I got a feeling you're gonna figure
something out
it has happened too because I can't do
this I can't do this anymore
so please please pray for me